[Music]
the reason why Facebook and Google are
so easy to hack is because their
business models are so easy to hack
now both Facebook and Google when they
started out said that what will make
them superior to the things they're
replacing is that they're going to be ad
free because they knew from square one
if they were going to have advertising
then the entire platform could be
leveraged for the opposite of its
original purpose so Google when they
were fighting against Yahoo they said oh
no we're gonna be the peoples algorithm
we're gonna use the way that people all
linked to other things as though as the
way in which we deliver search and
unlike Yahoo which is basically ads
supported in all this well what is
Google now Google is the world's biggest
advertising agency likewise Facebook
said no no no we're not going to use ads
are not going to be we're just going to
be there for people to be able to
connect with one another it's going to
all be social so it's going to be honest
and free and they became an ad-supported
platform too so what's happening is
their business models are being
leveraged by companies that understand
Facebook wants attention by any means
necessary and as long as that's their
goal they might not be conscious of it
as long as that's the goal of the
platform then they're gonna be used that
way the only way to create a social
network or a technology platform that is
resistant to this kind of social anti
human abuse is to know what your
platform is for and for that to stay
part of your operation as long as you go
what is the app for if you know what the
app is for I know it sounds so silly but
if you know what the app is for then you
can't get as confused by your
shareholder demands because oh no no
that's not what this app is for the
other big trick in maintaining control
of the purpose of a technology or a
company is not to take too much money
but back when and
I love them when I saw Evan Williams the
founder of Twitter one of them on the
cover of The Wall Street Journal with
the number you know four point three
billion dollars under his face it was
the morning that that Twitter went
public I thought there goes there's no
way for this guy and this beautiful 140
word messaging app there's no way for it
to deliver that many hundreds of
billions of dollars back to its
shareholders you know two billion
dollars a year for a hundred and forty
character messaging app which is about
what they make that is great could you
imagine grandma I made 140 character
messaging app we make two billion
dollars a year that should be the win
that's the success but it's not because
the way that that digital business works
now is people take as much money as they
can to get the highest valuation they
can and that's just a Ponzi scheme
there's no way to win so you end up
having to pivot your company away from
whatever a great human goal you may have
had indexing the world's information my
god what a great goal Google had it's no
longer indexing the world's information
it's become the world's information and
that's a very different thing so now we
live in Google rather than Google
indexing the world of the real world you
know the map becomes the territory and
that's when we all get lost
[Music]